bonjour sébastien boussois merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin en
direct sur rt france alors une
délégation belge été c'est également à
tenter en tout cas de se rendre dans ce
camp de réfugiés en syrie en vain comme
les députés français qu'elle est quelle
est la situation pour la belgique sur
cette question de rapatriement qui qui
gêne particulièrement le gouvernement
français en général la belgique est
assez suiviste par rapport à la france
on est dans la même situation depuis des
années que ce soit les informations que
l'on ait de la croix rouge qui est la
principale organisation qui nous permet
savoir encore combien de jeunes
d'enfants de femmes de combattants sont
sur place et qui ont encore les derniers
éléments d'information les plus viables
je dirais sur la situation dans les
camps de 2,2 à lol notamment que ce soit
le délégué général aux droits de
l'enfant qui suit cette affaire de près
et qui comme les organisations avec
lesquelles je travaille comme conseil
belgium par exemple on estime encore à
une cinquantaine les mineurs les enfants
qui sont qui sont sur place et pour
lequel on ne parvient en réalité à rien
depuis des années c'est à dire qu'il ya
un combat claire entre les aspirations
politiques et celle de l'opinion
tout ça est encore extrêmement ancrée
dans l'inconscient collectif que ces
enfants sont des graines de terroristes
que ces femmes sont dangereuses
or le processus était de 2-2 les
récupérer de les juger ici et puis de
permettre et d'aider ces gamins ces
mineurs qui n'ont rien demandé à
personne de d'essayer de reconstruire
une vie normale or on est en train de
construire le strict inverse c'est à
dire que il ya risque à tout moment et
ça a été le cas qu'un certain nombre fui
les camps qu'il meure ou que des
combattants particulier se rapatrie sur
d'autres terrains de djihad et en
attendant on laisse des traumatismes
s'installer chez les gamins pour lequel
ça sera encore plus difficile à l'avenir
soit ils seront comme tous les comme sur
tous les terrains de guerre en irak et
ailleurs c'est à dire avec des
traumatismes psychologiques extrêmement
lourd et difficile à résorber soit
certain mon avis partiront
combattre un moment ou à un autre parce
que ils seront dans cette situation où
ils auront été abandonnée de tout le
monde et en particulier d'état dont ils
font partie pour lequel ils ont la
nationalité et pour ces femmes justement
à propos de nationalité la déchéance de
nationalité est prévu en belgique
c'est pas une question de de prévoir où
je ne sais quoi certains on était
certains ont été remballés notamment au
maroc mais la question concerne les
personnes qui seraient binational en
général elles purgent leur peine
elles peuvent purger leur peine ici puis
ensuite été expulsée au maroc où est
directement expulsé au maroc pour purger
leur propre peine la situation n'est pas
aussi simple que ça sassou tant que du
coup vous ne pouvez pas être apatride ou
sans aucune nationalité votre sujet
votre question du coût concerne le même
débat qu'il y avait en france en 2015
avec l'ancien premier ministre manuel
valls les personnes qui seraient
binational alors vous avez énormément de
combattants qui sont tout à fait belge
belgo belge et donc qui n'ont
strictement rien à voir avec cette
notion de binationalité qui permettrait
la déchéance donc faut bien comprendre
que l'on ne s'adresse pas à une une
population unique et avec un canevas
unique de profils d'individus mais à une
grande à une grande diversité et les
choses varie d'un pays à l'autre on a
aujourd'hui à peu près dix mille
combattants étrangers ou enfin
combattants et famille dans le camp de a
lol et pour l'instant les lois qui
friment sont les lois du sol sur lequel
ils sont et notamment sur le sol irakien
où l'on parle pas de déchéance de
nationalité aux caisses des personnes
sont directement condamné à mort ce qui
est en tension et en est en opposition
complète avec les lois de la république
pour la france où comme pour la belgique
pour lequel la peine demain jusqu'à
nouvel ordre et est interdite et a été
abolie
sébastien boussois il y avait beaucoup
de djihadistes un parti de belgique pour
aller combattre dans les rangs de l'état
islamique concernant les enfants c'est
évidemment une question à part mais
concernant ces femmes où on en a vu
certaines n'avoir aucun regret
de s'être engagé sur ce terrain comment
est-ce que vous gérer cette question de
la presse quand elles sortiront de
prison lorsqu'elles sont rentrés en
belgique la question en tout cas
inquiète beaucoup en france
oui j'allais dire comment vous la gérez
en france aussi c'est la même chose je
suis sur les deux terrains on est tous
très angoissée par rapport aux sorties
de prison de 2022
une fois que des personnes ont été
condamnées qu'elles ont purgé leur peine
a priori elles sont totalement blanchi
et donc du coup devrait s'inscrire dans
un autre processus toute la difficulté
est de savoir ce qui a été fait pendant
tout ce temps là en prison et ça c'est
le plus difficile ça l'est à ben ali
avec lequel je travaille à la
possibilité de pouvoir interagir
directement dans les prisons certains
jihadistes ont même demandé à nous
rencontrer comme une sorte de chemin de
croix si je puis dire en tout cas pour
essayer de comprendre ou de prouver et
de montrer ou de construire un processus
de désengagement et la prison n'a jamais
été le modèle le plus évident et puis il
y a notamment au sein de ces belgium la
possibilité d'aller directement par
exemple dans les ip pj les instituts
pour mineurs et pour essayer de
d'empêcher que ces gamins qui sont à des
délinquants puissent basculer un moment
une autre face à une idéologie la
difficulté que pour la france comme pour
la belgique
nous ne sommes pas tout à fait prêt si
ce n'est allé mettre un bracelet
électronique mais ça ça nécessite encore
une décision de justice nous sommes pas
forcément prêts et n'anticipons pas
forcément et les sorties de prison mais
pour anticiper les sorties il faudrait
qu'ils aient un processus suffisant au
sein même des établissements
pénitentiaires et c'est à peu près comme
tous les sujets sur lequel l'état est
relativement le fait ou en tout cas
s'est désengagé pour des raisons
financières
les prisons aujourd'hui sont encore un
accélérateur de particules radical si je
puis dire et qui du coup peuvent soit
enracinée les plus les plus endurcis
soit faire s'effondrer d'autres quand
vous sortez de prison il faut construire
un projet en tout cas c'est ce que la
société devrait offrir pour éviter que
ces individus soient à un moment ou un
autre
un nouveau danger pour elle-même merci
beaucoup sébastien boussois d'avoir
répondu à nos questions dans la matinale
de rtl france le rappelle vous êtes
spécialiste des questions de terrorisme
et chercheur en relations
internationales
[Musique]